this is what the North Korean economy
looks like from the inside a silk
factory in the capital Pyongyang when
North Korea declared its goal of
developing nuclear weapons complete its
leader Kim jong-un said that from now on
the focus would be single mindedly on
economic development the message the
regime wanted to send today as they
showed us around under the strict
control of government minders was one of
innovation this worker told us that the
employees had completely modernized the
factory recently a comrade also talked
about improvements she said she was it
very enjoyable and that she has to give
thanks to the supreme leader
despite the modernization more
traditional views about the manager here
gave Kim jong-un himself a tour of the
factory I asked about the effect of
sanctions on his Factory he said the
Western imperialists had been imposing
them since 1945 but Koreans don't care
because we are not the spirit of
self-reliance we're not afraid this was
a propaganda exercise but propaganda can
be revealing it shows us what story the
North Korean regime wants to tell about
itself and that's important for
understanding how it acts on the world
stage has always been masterful at
garnering a 10
what is quite a small country has been
at the forefront of international
politics for such a long time and you
see that by military provocation by
nuclear test by missile launches so now
it's got the world's attention it wants
to tell a different story what's talk
about economy factories like this
innovation try and ship the narrative to
say its future might be very different
than his cause North Korea is right now
at a critical moment as it seeks to find
its way through an apparent stalemate
with the US over denuclearization via a
flurry of diplomatic activity of the
last week the nursery teachers being
trained at this College are singing from
the same innovation hymn sheet they were
keen to show off various gizmos
buzzwords like virtual reality Holograms
and artificial intelligence are just as
beguiling here as they are in the West
for all the talk of economic reform it
is an old-fashioned Leninist
dictatorship that rules here that
paradox is at the heart of North Korea
it will be on show at an expected
military parade here on Sunday and in
the difficult line it continues to walk
between proud isolation and
international engagement between showing
off its military might and avoiding
diplomatic provocation between political
repression and economic openness Tom
Cheshire Sky News in Pyongyang North
Korea